social media lately you may have seen
the trend where people share their red
flags and their green flags well to play
off of that today relationship coach
theresa batty joins us here to talk
about which flags to look out for when
it comes to dating good to see you again
thank you for having me again of course
perfect timing on valentine's day and
let's keep it positive let's start with
the green flags first what are some
positive things to look at yeah
definitely they say whatever you focus
on expands and you have a higher chance
of experiencing in real life so green
flags are better than red flags for sure
first number one thing to think about is
if somebody's um
saying
and their actions actually match okay
because if they do then you can actually
trust in what they're telling you and
let go of control and being worried
about like oh
he's told me this she told me this is
going to happen so if that happens it's
much calmer the environment changes we
can bring trust into a relationship and
everything rolls much better
that's number one thing number two is
transparency
a hundred percent transparency not
ninety percent not ninety-five percent
ninety-eight percent hundred percent if
somebody is ready to be like an open
book share everything with you which
means they have to be somewhat at peace
with their past and they have to be have
a clear past have gone through some
growth to be able to share everything
and be like an open book and i think if
i want to put the number third in there
it would be communication okay and um
communication in a way that you know any
relationship at some point is going to
start having conflict a relationship
with that conflict doesn't exist so
being able to be willing and open to
have communication about the conflicts
and coming out of it and actually
getting back together again stronger
rather than letting the conflict
separating you which happens a lot if
somebody is not open to communication it
doesn't matter if their communication
skill is not there just being willing to
work through issues that's one of the
biggest green flags and then red flags
really quickly just what should we watch
out for whether you're dating married
you know across the board well opposite
of the three that i told you
especially if uh there is any hiding
anything um not being comfortable to
leave everything open that that's a big
one and also um if there's any sort of
control in a relationship and control
doesn't always come in traditional ways
of
yelling at each other or why didn't you
go there any of that sometimes it's just
neglecting somebody's emotions sometimes
it's not validating how you feel and um
that's the huge red flag well thank you
so much for breaking all this down
really quickly where can people find you
if they uh they need your help best if
social media parishada baddie or my
website piratesobaddy.com thank you so
much happy valentine's day and let's
just only hope for green flags moving
forward las vegas